it's the film that skyrocketed tom
cruise to superstardom back in 1986 and
the sequel perhaps the most highly
anticipated movie in decades good
morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
taking on
the sequel to top gun was a daunting
task fans all over the world more than
any other film for decades have been
saying please do another one the
foundation of the story that we have
in this film originated back in 1986
afterwards
the dynamic of that relationship we
talked about back then so that was there
uh originally
so a long time in the pipeline and if
you're over 40 this might excite you
but will post-millennials get it i think
it's a great balance of being an homage
to the original um that's really fun and
um
nostalgic but also bring something new i
think it's a surprising
it's surprisingly emotional and also
again the flying what they're able to do
is completely on another level
not many films get to indulge in talk of
their own legacy but as this brings
crews full circle this movie's come to
mean a lot to a lot of people you know
we've we've all gotten older and we make
different decisions than we maybe would
have
in our in our 20s and words like
responsibility and duty and friendship
and loyalty and all of those things mean
something different i think i think
that's why people are responding so
emotionally to film i think they really
are
uh
kind of growing up with it it's it's an
amazing thing to see
so as cruz climbs back in the cockpit
for one final flight it seems you're
never too old for this kind of
adrenaline rush or heartwarm appeal
claire gregory sky news
and if you're feeling the need for uh
the speed we'll be live on the red
carpet it's the tongan premiere this
evening from 5 p.m and also you can see
that exclusive interview with tom cruise
in full in tom cruise colon maverick
this saturday at 8pm on sky showcase and
sky max